this is what I'm after this is what I'm
after something like this what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to generalize
right I'm trying to see if its largest
true in the case we just looked at but
always true mathematicians are always
after this kind of thing right it's
called abstraction you get rid of
concrete numbers and figure out what's
true all the time no matter what numbers
you tried it okay so you remember how we
began we began weird X double dot and
then I supplied a number as soon as I
supplied a number it became a specific
situation but I want it to be true all
the time so I'm going to come back to
this guy okay so that's all I'm
establishing right and the way I made
progress from here to something Theus
was I put it together with this this is
what my head is right okay so in other
words we're looking acceleration we're
looking at from two different angles
okay what are we going to get well let's
let's try doing this approach what we
did before but doing it in general terms
what's going to happen okay what am I
god I've got this is equal to this done
right so far so good still got my
equations in terms of X so integrate and
you'll get this
does that check out just integrated
their problems okay now i'm getting
towards something like this anti I'm
getting there okay but I've got two
problems number one it's not in terms of
me square number two I stairs constant
flying around right well on a second
let's get rid of the half that's not
hard to do okay how do they get rid of
the constant last time we had an initial
condition right hmm I'm not giving you
any conditions I'm giving you nothing it
can be any kind of simple harmonic
motion ok but this cost that can't be
anything right I can still work out what
this is now as a bit tricky have you
said to me initial conditions but
actually we didn't end up using initial
conditions here to get to this do you
remember we didn't actually need to know
about time what do we need to know yeah
we needed a relationship between
displacement and morsi's no time there
so I don't care if its initial or not
okay so you've got a couple of ways to
approach this couple of ways right for
instance um you can say look about this
motion okay I don't know why all I know
basically is that it's got the center of
motion being the origin it's basically
all in it okay but that gives me some
information for instance well at the
origin in theory i should actually know
how fast I'm going should the night
that's that's when I'm going fastest
okay now i don't i know we don't know
about any of the numbers are we don't
know whatever to use we don't know what
period is but i can still work it out
alternately i should be able to say at
the extremities the airport's you right
either of the extremities I should know
the velocity right what will nicety be
it will be 0 right this is actually the
situation we got before except they just
told us one of the examples okay an
instance on that right now you can go at
this sorry what you'll find is that
you'll have this velocity okay it's not
that hard to determine think about it
I'm going to go with this the numbers
are a little bit simpler watch what
happens okay i'm going to substitute
that in here because everything's being
squared it doesn't matter whether you
take a positive or negative I'm just
going to take the positive anyway okay
when I'm at the Plaza big show d I have
velocity 0 okay sitting he goes let's c
0 equals you happy with that is that ok
i'll just something in so now i have to
see to see is just a square n square so
i can bring his back into this equation
minus N squared x squared ah you see the
merging they go take your factor out did
I take a vendre no sorry not that one
I actually had it
they go so there's your proof that this
is not just a coincidence it is actually
true all the time p squared okay
alternatively you could have gone this
way do you want to see it it doesn't
take very long wash instead I'll take
the origin is my point of reference hmm
by the way what does this tell you the
more frequent the period er the graph is
and the higher has to go the faster is
coming back through the origin past the
origin I guess okay because you know
think about this if I have this graph
and I increase the amplitude right like
this okay obviously he's coming back
fast up past the origin in the same way
if I think about this guy and I increase
the frequency to something like this
again he's coming back faster across the
origin right so these are your two
factors that affect your velocity past
the origins where am I here's the
equation I'm something into I think so v
equals a.m. that's the left-hand side
equals R squared plus 2c Oh surprise
look you get the same constant and back
you go okay so I could have taken either
of these reference points and they would
have supplied me with the same result at
the end okay you cannot quote this
result you cannot quote it you have to
arrive at in much the same way that we
have except you have numbers in its
place okay however because it started
from this point what it means is this is
an independent way of verifying that
something as simple harmonic motion okay
if you see this you're like tick that
means it's super hard mission right if
you see this in exactly the same way you
can say well it came from there these
are parallel results they just look at
it from another angle okay so it's
another way to verify okay